PROFESSOR: So connectivity
is more than just
an all or nothing affair.
We can talk about how
connected a graph is.
So let's begin
with two vertices.
Two vertices are said
to be k-edge connected
if they remain connected
if you remove fewer
than k edges from the graph.
Let's look at an example.
So here's a graph, and let's
focus on those two vertices
that I've highlighted
in magenta.
They are 1-edge connected
because they're connected,
and if you remove one edge
they become disconnected.
So they're 1-edge connected, but
they're not 2-edge connected.
In particular, if
I delete that edge,
then they no longer is a
path between the two magenta
vertices.
Here's an example of
two vertices, these two
green vertices, that
are 2-edge connected.
That means that I can remove any
number of edges less than two,
which is to say one edge,
and they'll stay connected.
But if I do remove two vertices,
they become disconnected.
So with those two edges
judiciously selected,
there will no longer be a path
between the two green vertices.
For a 3-edge
connected example, we
can look at these two
vertices highlighted in purple
and discover that we can
remove any two edges,
and they're still going
to be stuck together.
You can kind of see that
because they're in a cycle here
and in a cycle there.
And in order to
break them, you're
going to have to break
both cycles, which means
two edges to break two cycles.
And if you remove three,
on the other hand,
you can separate them.
So if I cut these
three edges-- might
have been more obvious
to cut that one,
but I'm doing it this way
to make it interesting--
if I cut these three
edges, then in fact I
wind up with no path
between those two vertices.
So they are 3-edge connected
but not 4-edge connected.
Meaning you can remove two,
but you can't remove three
and keep them connected.
For a whole graph, a
whole graph is k-edge
connected if every two
vertices are k-edge connected.
And the point of this
degree of connectivity
is to measure-- one
motivation of it
is if you think of this graph
as indicating a communication
network, where vertices are
centers that are sending
and receiving data,
and an edge corresponds
to having some kind
of a channel or cable
between adjacent centers.
Then connectivity is a measure
of how many of your channels
or cables can go down and
still have the property
that every center
of information can
communicate with every
other center of information.
So how many connections can
fail without cutting off
communication?
Here's an example of a
graph that globally-- this
was the graph that we saw before
that has some vertices that
are 1-edge connected, others
that are 2, others that are 3.
But the graph as a
whole is only 1-edge
connected because there's this
one edge that can be removed
that splits it in two.
This graph, on the other
hand, a modification of it,
is 2-edge connected.
Now I can remove any
one edge, and no matter
what single edge I
remove, this will
remain a connected graph, which
makes it 2-edge connected.
Now, there's a corresponding
definition of vertex connected,
meaning it's k-vertex
connected if you
can remove any number
of vertices up to k
and it will stay connected.
If it's k-vertex connected,
it's certainly k-edge connected,
but not conversely.
Here's a graph that is 2-edge
vertex connected but 1-vertex
connected.
If you remove one
vertex, it breaks.
If you remove that
But on the other hand,
it needs two edges
to be cut in order to
split the graph in two.
The complete graph on n
vertices is-- to cut it up,
it requires cutting
n minus 1 edges
and, in fact, n minus 1
vertices to break it up
because everything is
connected to everything else.
So Kn is as connected
a graph on n
vertices as you
can possibly have.
But of course, it's
got a lot of edges.
It's got n choose
2 edges, or about n
times n minus 1 over 2 edges.
Another interesting structure
is the n-dimensional hypercube.
So the square is
a 2-dimensional,
and the cube, the ordinary cube
is the H3, has eight vertices
and looks like a cube.
And in general, the
way we define Hn
is that its vertices are the
binary strings of length n.
And two vertices are adjacent
if they differ in one bit.
They're the same except
that in one coordinate
one of them has a 1
and the other has a 0.
In that case, you can
make the edges adjacent.
It turns out that the
n-dimensional hypergraph
is n-vertex connected.
And this is worked out in a
homework or a class problem.
So to summarize-- well,
actually before we summarize,
there's a basic theorem that
we're not going to prove.
It's just a little bit
too much of a challenge
for us to get into.
It would take maybe a
couple of lectures--
is to prove Menger's theorem,
which says that a graph is
k-vertex connected if and only
if you can connect any two
vertices with completely
non-overlapping different paths
k of them.
So if two vertices
are k-connected,
then there are completely
separate, k separate paths
connecting them, which
means, of course,
that you have to cut
each of the paths
in order to separate them.
And a similar theorem
goes for edge connected.
So to summarize
about some graphs
that we know about, given that
connectivity measures fault
tolerance in a network,
we're interested in, well,
how many edges did
it take to achieve
this level of connectivity?
So the number of edges is
kind of a measure of the cost.
And the complete graph on
n vertices is n minus 1
connected, but it has about
n squared over 2 edges.
The hypercube.
Now, if we're going to be
talking about graphs of size n
to be uniform, the hypercube
on Hn has 2 to the n vertices.
So if we want an
n-vertex version,
we're talking about h sub
log n, which has n vertices.
And then it has about
n log n over 2 edges.
So it's got fewer edges
than the complete graph
but significantly
less, exponentially
less connectivity.
The grid is simply like
the x, y axis or the x,
y plane with points at integers
so that every node is connected
to four adjacent nodes--
one up, one down, one right,
and one left.
Now of course, when you
get to the edge of it,
if you make it finite,
the ones on the edge
are only going to
be 2-connected.
So you have to wrap it around
in the shape of a donut
to really make it work
with a finite graph.
But if you do that,
then the thing
is 4-connected-- 4-edge
connected and only has
2n edges.
And then a cycle is 2-connected.
A cycle of size n is
2-connected with n vertices.
And finally, trees, which
we'll talk about next time,
are the smallest possible
connected graphs.
They are 1-connected.
Indeed everything in
a tree is connected,
and they only have
n minus 1 edges.
But if you remove
one edge, it splits.
And that's sort of the summary
of the k-connectivity story.